نؤكد ان العمليه العسكريه التي بدات
بالامس وسببت الكثير من الخسائر للمنظمه
الارهابيه ستستمر داخل تركيا وخارجها
وسنعطي الجواب المناسب
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
اردوغان يقولوا ان العمليات في شمال سوريا
والعراق لن تقتصر على القذف الجوي وان
القاده العسكريين يجرون تقيما بشان عمليه
بريه في وقت اعلن فيه وزير الداخليه
التركي مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص بينهم طفل اسره
سقوط قذائف على الحدود مع سوريا
الحدث الثوري الايراني ينفذ ضربات صاروخيه
وغارات بطائرات مسيره ضد مقر تابعه لاحزاب
ايرانيه معارضه داخل اقليمي كردستان
العراق حكومه الاقليم اذنت الهجوم وقالت
ان العنفه لن يحقق الاستقرار في حين قال
لتنتجون انه يعرض امن العراقي والمنطقه
للخطر
مقتل العشرات واصابه المئات في زلزال ضرب
محافظه
الاندونيسيه الزلزال تسبب بتهدم مئات
المباني
ترابيه وقطع الطرق المؤديه لبعض القرى ومن
المتوقع ارتفاع عدد ضحايا مع استمرار
عمليات البحث والانقاذ
منتخبات اوروبيه تعلن تراجعها عن فكره
ارتداء اشاره دعم المثليين خلال مباريات
كاس العالم في قطر وذلك بعد ترويح الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم بفرد عقوبات صارمه على
اللاعبين في حال خلقت